The class projects will be based on the Raven's Progressive Matrices test of
intelligence. This test was written in the 1930s to examine general human
intelligence. It consists of 60 multiple-choice visual analogy problems.
The Raven's test is unique among intelligence test in that all problems in
the Raven's test are strictly visual. No words. It is the most widespread,
the most commonly used, the most reliable test of intelligence. The Raven's test
consists of two kinds of problems, two by two matrix problems and
three by three matrix problems. We'll also consider a special case of
two by one matrix problems. They're not part of the original test. But
they will providing a baseline for starting to construct AI agents. Your project
will be to implement AI agents that can solve problems like those that appear in
the Raven's Test of Intelligence. Let's look at a few sample problems right now.